And now the old scout master.
This is the week we get ready to go canoeing up in Canada.
We're packing gear and buying food and you know we go up there
And I've got a couple of scouts who are pretty keen fishermen
And the last time we were up there they found this great spot on one of the lakes
And they wanted to remember it because they caught a couple of fish there.
So one leaned out of the canoe and put a big X in the side of the canoe
And the other scout said: why in the world are you doing that?
And the first one said: well, X marks the spot.
This way we'll remember our fishing spot.
And the other scout said: how stupid can you be?
I mean, what if we get a different canoe from the outfitter next time?
What if we get a different canoe?
Okay,
Hey, this is my guest number 131..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag here.
Well, we heard from Ron Blaisdell
Recently. on the blog we've been talking about 4%,
which is a new Eagle Scout history in the centennial year of the Eagle Scout here
published by Mike Malone,
And Mike is an award-winning author and just did a fantastic job of research
and created this definitive, authoritative Eagle Scout history
And I know you'll enjoy it.
Get over to scoutmastercgcom and take a look.
But Ron wrote in. he said thanks for the heads up on the Kindle edition of the book.
Just purchased it, downloaded it and read the intro.
It's great stuff already.
One of the other posts on the blog recently was on the quality of an Eagle Scout
And Mike Loads wrote in to say: Clark, this was well said
and, for me, very timely. thanks for sharing it.
Tracy Lucas said: Clark, as always, your words help.
We're trying to shift our focus away from keeping up with other Scout Masters
and onto our Scouts.
What better role to have than be in the young man's cheering section
as he advances towards Eagle?
Isn't that our primary role? anyway?
Where it goes from here is up to him.
Our task is to set him on the pass.
Thank you, thank you. thank you, Clark.
Well, thank you, Tracy.
Thanks for being in touch
While I was away at Scout Camp the other week
and John Collins ran in to say: great idea,
I would have killed for an Altoid Box full of pushpins this summer at camp.
All right, maybe I wouldn't have killed,
but I certainly would have arm wrestled somebody for it.
Yeah, that was just a bunch of stuff that I'd take to camp.
I thought it might be interesting.
We heard from Kiff over in the UK.
He's a blogger with a blog called I think it's jabbering all day long
about scouting in the UK
And he commented on our post on poisonous snakes.
He says this shows the amazing difference
between your everyday adventure and ours here in the UK.
There is only one poisonous snake in the UK, the Adder.
They're found in the grass and morelands
and it's more like that. you will see the tail disappearing into the grass.
then you'll actually get to see the snake,
With bears, snakes and raccoons stealing your food.
you'll never go camping.
I guess it's just the different adventures that life throws at a scout.
Well, Kiff, thanks for being in touch.
We'll keep up with the blog over there and it's always interesting.
So on this podcast,
owning to a scheduling conflict, it says here
we didn't get our Scoutmaster panel together for this month.
I mean, everybody's off doing things,
I'm off doing things and we just didn't get everybody together.
But I thought it would be interesting to go back to our first
Scoutmaster panel discussion, which I thought was a pretty good one,
And so I'm going to rebroadcast that this week on the podcast,
And I also have a couple of quick email questions and answers
that will feature,
And that should be enough for this podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
Everything that feels just as it should.
You're part of a life there,
You're part of something good
If you've ever wandered lonely through the woods,
If you've ever been out walking through the woods.
So, on the Scoutmasters podcast, today
we're trying a little experiment.
We've got a panel of Scoutmasters put together
and we're going to talk about,
after we've been through this for several years,
how we would advise a new Scoutmaster,
what we would tell him that we know now
that we didn't know then.
From Vera, Florida, Larry Geiger is joining me,
and Larry has been a Scoutmaster
for several different troops over the years
and is now an Assistant Scoutmaster for the troop.
he was most recently Scoutmaster for
Troop 720 there in Vera.
How you doing today, Larry?
Good,
I'm good.
Tom Gillard is in Telehoma, Tennessee,
where he is the Scoutmaster of Troop 402..
Welcome to the podcast, Tom.
Thank you very much.
And Walter Underwood is a past Scoutmaster of Troop 14,
and is now the Assistant Scoutmaster
for their Venture Patrol.
And Walter is in Palo Alto, California.
Howdy, Walter.
Hi, Larry.
Larry, we said that you were a Scoutmaster
for several different troops.
If we put all those years together,
how many years do you figure you spent as a Scoutmaster?
I think it's 14..
Tom- same question-
18..
18 years.
And Walter,
It's about six, though I started up with Cubs,
so I've worked my way up through Assistant and Leader all the way.
Were you involved in Cubs, Tom?
No, we didn't actually have very many Cubs
When I was growing up. we didn't,
but my kids were, and I guess I did the weeblows thing
with the boys before we went into Boy Scouts
When they started camping. that's what got you interested.
Yeah, that's it.
How about you, Larry,
Have any involvement with Cubs?
I was the weeblows leader for one year for my eldest son.
You guys all have the experience
of having worked in Cub Scouting,
making the transition up to Boy Scouts.
What kind of person makes a good Scoutmaster?
And I'll turn to you first, Larry.
I think a lot of Scoutmasters
are kind of in a middle position somewhere.
They're not usually CEOs or guys that are really, really busy.
It's usually somebody that understands leadership
and can do some of that,
but is not necessarily a business owner
or somebody that's so busy they don't have time for it.
And then it's somebody that loves working with Scouts,
that wants to really get in there, either with their own son
or with- if they don't have a son-
somebody that really wants to work with them
and to learn and to grow.
What would you add to that, Tom?
Well, the person would have to be willing to try different things,
to go a little bit outside his comfort zone,
get out of the box type stuff.
And Walter, what would you add?
I think, especially coming over from Cubs,
you need someone who has the patience to watch boys fail
as they learn.
If you can watch boys try to light a fire for 30 minutes
without saying anything.
And the other thing is you have to be really solid in the ideals,
the oath and law and in what you're about,
and that it's citizenship, character and fitness,
because you end up explaining this all the time.
It's not the same as soccer teams,
And especially with parents.
you need to be very solid when somebody comes in
and says why isn't my son a patrol leader?
It's like, well, because this is how we do it.
So patience, are you as patient now as you were
when you started out as a scout master, Walter.
I have learned the scout master position,
which is one hand in your pocket
and the other holding a cup of coffee.
How about you, Larry?
I think I'm way more patient than I was when I started-
Less flappable, more unflappable, I think the term-
And all three of you had sons involved.
What are we looking out for when we take on that position
and our sons involved?
Well, I don't want to show favoritism to my own son,
So there's a whole lot of let one of the other assistants
take care of stuff that happens with your son
and you'll take care of, like his son.
And Larry, what was your experience?
My guys and I, I don't think, had a problem with that.
I've asked them about that.
They're both fairly independent
and they both had good friends in the troop
that they hung out with.
I did a few of their scout master conferences.
some other assistant scout masters did them.
I think it worked out pretty well.
Walter, what was your experience?
Well, when I was asked to be scout master,
I asked my son about it
and he thought it was a terrible idea.
He came around and in fact he was SPL
and I was scout master.
That worked out pretty well.
but it was really nice to have
hand that over to another scout master-
and he was still SPL
and let me be able to see them work together.
So patients, having a little bit of
you, end up having those things that you do as a father
and those things that you do as a scout master
and that can be kind of fuzzy at times.
It can be kind of hard to figure.
What challenges do you expect
a new scout master is going to meet,
Sometimes trying to do
I can do it better myself
or it won't get done. right if I don't do it-
Mentality, and you've got to realize
that it will get done.
It won't be the way you wanted it to,
but it will get done if you ask
and everybody's behind the program.
So you've got to be careful with that.
I'm a delegator
and I don't have a lot of problem with that.
When I give something to somebody
before long as people come around,
I give it all away
until, the truth is, I just don't have much to do.
but for some reason I don't have a lot of anxiety
like some guys do about that.
I was a scout from my 11th birthday,
the day of, until I was 18..
So I had kind of a background.
I did. I thought,
And I think for me
working with the Scouts
wasn't as much as working with the parents,
the moms and the committee.
That opened up more of the challenges sometimes.
I want to get back to that.
Larry, you were fairly experienced in scouting.
You had some background.
Tom, how about you?
I joined when I was 11
and eagled out at 18.
I was one of those late eagles
but I went all the way through the program. also,
I was a Cub Scout.
I was a Scout through 18..
I was on summer camp staff one summer
when I was in college,
So I had plenty of experience. I thought:
Do you think that somebody without any background in it
can actually take the job on?
The guy that preceded me was a retired Navy guy.
He was never a Scout and he had daughters
And he was Scout Master for three years.
He did very well
And he was a very good Scout Master
and really loved the kids.
So yeah, I absolutely think that
if it's the right person, they can do that.
I think that with the network,
that there is something like this,
with the internet, with roundtables,
with the training, yes, you could do it,
You could be a good Scout Master
with no background in the program.
The two Scout Masters that followed me
have been both. either one had
a Scouting experience growing up.
You certainly have to help them along
at Scout Master Emeritus
and give them hints here and there.
We're also lucky. our boys are very,
very particular about leading the operation.
If you try to step in, they will let you know
that it is a boy-led troop
and you're doing it wrong.
Even if you don't have a whole background
of Scouting experience as a youth,
that you can still do this
if you go and take advantage
of the different support networks
that are available.
If you kind of listen to people
who've got a little bit of experience-
Larry, you started talking a little bit
about working with parents,
working with other volunteers-
I think that might-
I'm not saying that you saying that
would put people off- but I think
that would be a pretty big factor
in somebody who's thinking about taking
that into consideration.
I don't think I would have done
very well if I hadn't had very, very
strong committees.
Both times I've been a Scout Master
I've had, basically the whole time,
rooms full of people
From this troop. we average
about 15..
In my last troop, we average
20 to 35 in a committee meeting
And with all of those people in the
committee they get to know
kind of what's going on.
as people that are totally on the sidelines-
Particularly moms
of single moms-
They're not in committee meetings,
They're busy. It's just
harder sometimes, I think, for them.
I have a letter from a mom
about me, inflexible
and insufferable and I don't know.
a whole bunch of ins.
Unfortunately, my committee chairman
had a sense of humor.
I don't want to be negative about that.
It can be a challenge on occasions
working through that. Like you said,
when parents don't understand
why their son's not patrol leader,
you got to walk through that.
We're talking to somebody who
maybe is considering being a Scout Master,
who's a newly minted Scout Master,
and they're encountering some of these things
and you do get through them, don't you?
Yes,
Oh, absolutely.
I would agree that a committee chair
is really essential.
Our committee meetings are really a parent meeting.
We have them during the first
troop meeting of the month.
The parents are all over in another room,
Scout Masters typically there,
letting the SPL run the meeting.
We'll have the SPL come in and explain
something that's going on.
That really helps. I actually spent
more effort,
rebuilding the connection
with our charter organization,
Kind of getting
reconnected with the pastor,
Having the whole troop show up
parish workdays
in troop t-shirts
and really just getting that
back on track.
I want to talk more about that,
but just talking about
overcoming those first couple of months
of resistance or difficulty
being
the new guy in the job,
Does anybody have anything
that they specifically remember from that time?
The way I look at it,
my committee chairman and I
are in charge and responsible
for everything.
Anything in the troop that doesn't happen.
there's not somebody to cover,
we do.
The idea is
we don't push people
to do stuff, even the scouts.
We say what we want is everybody to do
what they're trained,
experience and comfortable doing.
If you work it that way,
eventually it takes time sometimes
but eventually you'll find a guy that wants
to be treasurer for eight years
and he never loses a penny
Because he's doing what
he wants to do. If you'd made him an advancement chair
or a committee chair,
you'd have had a disaster.
You just keep working through the same thing
with the scouts. Some guys
don't want to be SPL, They want to be instructors,
Some guys it just depends.
you have to work with them and find out
what exactly where they fit
and then encourage them
to go do that and do it. well,
That first period after you decided
that you would go ahead and take on the job,
that were particularly challenging.
It was a little bit like what Larry was talking about.
since we were a brand new troop,
we didn't have many adults
and I was doing a lot of the stuff.
but as we needed stuff,
even if there weren't
a position,
even if nobody volunteered for anything,
you could always go and ask
a parent
and if it was
a presented thing they would say,
sure, I'll do that,
and sort of got those things
off of me back into the committee
or then started getting the boys
to doing the stuff.
so it started shifting
back to where it should be
and leaving me
and the committee chair
doing what we're supposed to be doing.
Walter, you talked about
having to kind of rebuild
the chartered organization
relationship
as one of the challenges. Were there any others
that come easily to mind?
Well, when my
son joined
we had a big year
and the troop grew from 23 to 46 scouts
and then I became
scout master
that March.
so we were really adjusting
to being a more organized,
a little bit less seat of the pants
troop
and we had really excellent
outings. chair moved on.
that was a real adjustment to just get
more people stepping in
to do more things
because we were bigger,
and get the scouts used to doing
things as opposed to just a little group
that knew each other.
it's a bigger group, so that was
there was a real adjustment there
and I was shepherding a lot of that.
so, Walter, when you,
when your outdoor guy left,
did you and the committee chair pick that up
until, like, say, for six months,
until the right guy came
along? We did have somebody
volunteer and they were pretty good, but they weren't
nearly as good as the
the previous
guy. But did you get another one
eventually? Yes,
yes, we're
most recent outdoor chair moved on to be scout master
and now we have another one and so
that's really settled down
now that we've adjusted to the size we
are. and of course now we just got another 20
scouts, so we have to have another adjustment.
Well,
we've talked a lot about importance of a strong
troop committee. we've talked a little bit
about relating to the charter organization.
Larry, what's your
experience as far as the
importance of having good connections with
the charter organization? I was in troop 705
for about two years and
then it wasn't going real well. so we started
a new one and both my pastors were
eagle scouts- the current one
and the previous one- and we're extremely supportive.
it was an excellent
relationship. How about you, Tom?
They're very
standoffish but they are
in the charter organization.
he's got.
he's had three sons. two of
them have become eagles. the third one
is working very hard and he
is in the troop and he's
in the charter organization. so
he is our link.
and one of the other
key relationships
is relationship to the district
and the council. What are your thoughts on
that, fellas? Alright, this
will probably get censored, but
I encourage people
to take training, but particularly
in my first troop I kept
most of my guys fairly isolated. I went to
round table and
in the rest of the
the district at the time was the kind of
thing where if I brought my
committee they'd have nabbed them.
when you say that, you mean they would have
asked them to volunteer and do something.
and
we ended up along the way with
50, 60, 70 scouts and
I sent the assistant scout masters
to training and
the main thing that we had a relationship with
the district was the district advancement
chair. but you have to have a good
relationship with the district advancement chair,
particularly if you're going to have eagle scouts.
that's essential. I don't know,
it depends on your troop. we have troops
that have trailers and they have
all kinds of gear and the biggest
thing of the year is the two
camperees and they set all this stuff up
and we're the guys that
you know that park at the gate and backpack in
and go back in the bushes.
That's sort of
us too. we're a very minimalist
backpacking troop. we don't have
a trailer. the district
and the roundtables, I think, are
pretty invaluable because you do
gain an awful lot of
knowledge. the
the other, the other scout
masters, the other committee district
people that are there
are more than willing to share their
experiences and you
find out- hey, you really aren't in this- by yourself
in the district,
and I was
the district advancement chair
for a couple years, I guess
a few years ago- and
that's a whole other. being on the
district side is a whole other,
whole another story. I think
the district is being
being associated in the district is
very useful. yeah, yes, I would agree
with that. I know I. I'm about to
find out about the other side. I've just been invited
to be on
the district advancement committee and help
approve eagle projects. so,
but no, our district is
very lightweight and helpful.
our troop is also a backpacking troop, as are
most of the troops around here,
like Tom. a lot
of what I get out of it is knowing
the other scout masters
right- that there's a, there's a real
camaraderie among the troops.
when I was a kid it seemed like there was a
rivalry between between the troops,
but nowadays it seems
like, especially
being on being an adult now,
everybody really tries to get along
with each other because
you're doing the same thing
now. one thing I'll mention that is:
we live in Florida and
it's it's hot and it's buggy. so
we go to Camp Daniel Boone in
Canton, North Carolina, which is the Asheville
Council. it's in the mountains, it's
3500 feet, it's cool, it's
beautiful. again, that
sets us off. if you
tend to go to your local
camp, you also make connections that
that we don't make more than just
your committee and the other people are working
with your troop. you can stretch
out a little bit. you can find some help,
assistance, some camaraderie
with people in your district and your council as well.
right, the council,
council is
the person you want to really know in
the council level is the secretary
for camping and the secretary for
advancement.
those are the two. yeah, they know how to
get things done absolutely.
let's talk a little bit about working
with, with your youth leaders.
there's different styles of
doing this. there's different ways of approaching it.
what's the dynamic
of the youth leadership?
so far as your role as scout master is involved,
if you focus on the,
the leaders,
and you kind of leave the other guys
alone, you begin to develop
that relationship where
the older guys take care of the younger
guys. everybody's different.
there, I guess, is what I would say, is
I've seen different scout masters, different ways,
and I'm
pretty much hands off most of the time,
but
people are more hands on and it seems to work
for them and the boys still do
the thing they still do- scouting. so
you know how you work that out,
and getting to know the guys when
you're brand new is just something
that you have to do as a scout master
and it's
it's the, especially the senior patrol
leader depends on how old he is,
how much experience
he might have, and
if he's
a go getter, you just
step back and let him go. if he's
very timid, you have
to say: well, you have to send
notes through emails the week
before and let him
let him cultivate that for the next meeting.
so
you know, the
age and maturity of your senior patrol
leader is going to affect how you handle
it,
no matter whether you're new or old,
right? but we're talking
about new guys here, right? I guess
that's what we're going to focus on. and
you don't know them when? well, you may
not, I don't know if you've been in the troop a while,
but if you walk in and you don't know them,
you have to develop that relationship.
well, that's true too. yeah,
so that is that's hard, coming in cold.
it is a real
delicate balance
between how much do you,
you know, let them
risk and fail
while you're still responsible for the program
of the troop.
so there's a real balance
of that
mentoring while
having the campouts happen and having things happen
on them and advancement, and
it's just hard, right, it's one of those
subtle
balance sorts of things that you just have to work out.
from my personal experience, it takes a while
to figure out exactly how it all works.
whether you've had any experience in scouting or not,
it takes a lot
of practice to
find all the subtleties of working
and motivating youth leaders.
well, it
depends on how much of it
is leading and motivating
and how much of it is them
finding their own way. it's a little
bit of both, because you're letting them go
to figure out
their own leadership ability. some of them,
you know, you can't
teach every kid, because every kid
is different. you teach them some
principles but then they have to go
and do that. some kids
are just loud and
a little bit bossy, but it works for them.
you know, another kid try that and
you know it's just like who are you?
and then other guys are just kind of quiet,
they're more in the background, and yet
guys just walk over and say, hey, what do you think
we should do? you know, so their
leadership styles can be very, very different
and they have to kind of
the scouts, have to kind of find that.
and that's where you
encourage them in their leadership. but
you don't drown it out.
hey, you know you're not doing
senior patrol, you're not doing enough of this,
you know, or that kind of thing. as opposed
to boy, you really handled that well.
how can you take
whatever you did there
and use it over
here in this situation?
and they have to figure that out. you can't
say, well, then you need to do that
because that won't work.
is there anything that you did-
any of you did particularly that you would
look back on? you say I would really I would
warn somebody not to do that-
had a great experience. part of our
part of growing was that we split into
more patrols and so we had
the leaders
to do that and they did a fantastic job.
and then one of the we have
assistant patrol leaders associated with
patrol, so there's their kind of liaisons,
and so someone had been with one of these patrols
for a long time,
looked at the result and said, well, some of the
scouts I've been with for all these years are now
patrol and could we change all this?
and I let him change.
and that was a mistake
because we
that haunted us for a couple of years because
they had a derange, so they were kind of younger,
kind of a bench for leadership. so
when the patrol leader moved on, and so we
ended up with one patrol that didn't have anybody
to fill in for the next patrol leader,
another patrol with too many older scouts
that all aged at once and boy,
yeah, I let the adults
mess with the boys decisions. that was
so, Walter. what you're describing is
the boys set up their own patrols
and then
you allowed the adults to kind of overrule that.
they just made some adjustments,
but it was very
finely balanced work. boys did a fantastic
job and it threw it out of balance.
hmm, that's interesting.
so the word I would use is
meddling, and I think
that's one of the regrets
I would have is I have meddled a couple of
times in SPL
elections and patrol
organization once
or twice. shouldn't have
we started to mess around
with the patrol
arrangement once and backed off?
I don't remember exactly why, but
we, we backed off of that.
but we've. we meddled around
trying to do troop rules
and you know,
and the troop rules
are her in the book,
so you know
what rules are you talking about specifically?
we were, we were trying to
get punishment rules.
you know if, if you do this,
this will happen. and we had
a trouble, trouble child
and we were trying to lay down more rules
to cover what he was doing
instead of going. you're
not living up to the oath and the law.
these are the rules. so that
that came
about and lasted for
a very short time and
it's. it's gone away
now. so, meddling
like thinking that
you're smarter than the boys, because a lot of
times we're not. well, I,
I don't know that that it's that we're
smarter sometimes we are, sometimes
he could do it better. but when we
metal, we take away
that learning process. whether they
would do it better, the same or less, it
doesn't matter. the point
is it's not whether we're smarter,
whether there's a better end result.
right is that they did it
and they learned one way or the other from
that, and that's the main.
the other, the other thing that came up
was overlaying a whole lot
of other things on top of the program
in the way of rules and regulations
and stuff like that
I've made. I made that mistake.
I, you know my hands up. I definitely
did that in the past
and found out that if
most of those rules and regulations
had any merit to them, they would
have been there in the first place.
can't go wrong if you stick
stick to the program. so we've talked a
lot about the different challenges
that you come across, some of the
relationships that you need to think
about, the way that you work with the
scouts, how about at home, how about
dealing with your family, your wife
and and how that all well,
I mean, everybody knows, you know I
go to work and I'm scouts.
you know my wife is, my boys have
always supported that.
everybody work, everybody that knows
me. he's the scout guy, you know, I guess
if you stick with it for a while that's going to kind of get attached
to you, that's associated
with you and with your wife.
so it's a family thing.
I agree completely.
you, you do.
you do become
the program. people do
recognize you because of
stuff you've done through the scouting.
and your,
your wife, does become
the, the wife of the scout master.
whether they know her or not,
they, they know that she's the wife of the scout master,
but she, she's
got to support it and
it my, my boys,
my youngest one aged
out eight years ago but
I'm still being allowed
to to participate.
you lost your ticket but
you still get to go on the ride. huh,
absolutely,
you're almost as old as the rest of
her. and Walter, what do you think
about that? oh, I'm a preachers
kid and my wife, my mom,
always made it very clear that she was not the preachers,
why she was,
and that that was her number one
as opposed to being just
another hand around the church and so
I tried to make sure that
it's it's really.
it's really my thing and it's really.
I get fantastic support
from the family
but that they're first.
now
Tina thought it was a little weird at first
with all these little kids running around in blue uniforms
and it is a little weird,
but they she's actually
around and volunteered and and organized
the board's review
for the past several years and has really
enjoyed talking to the scouts
in the boards. so it's been
great support. but it's
it's really important to
to keep that in balance.
so this group
has a number of years behind them
as being a volunteer leader in scouting
and
it's a lot. it's a lot to ask
of somebody. it
makes it. there's challenges and demands on
your time. any regrets?
would you recommend it to folks?
absolutely no regrets,
no regrets. I would.
I would encourage people to make sure that you
you find some enthusiasm in it.
if you like to hike, you know,
make sure that there's
that you're really having fun
doing.
yeah, I agree. no, no regrets
at all.
greatest:
well, you're the scout guy.
well, listen, I really appreciate everybody
joining in.
I hope folks will find this valuable.
and if you would like
us to talk about another subject in
scouting, or if you're having a
particular
problem or challenge, get in touch
and and we'll do it again. so
thank you, Larry. thank you, Clark,
it was great, you're welcome. and Tom,
thank you too, and good night.
yep and Walter,
it's been a pleasure
and it's been good to talk to y'all
and we'll we'll talk again soon.
write me a letter,
send it my name
email. that is, folks,
and here's an answer to one of your
emails.
well, here's some recent emails that
I am in with questions and here's a couple
answers for you. John from troop one
in Huntington Beach, California, wrote in
to say this: said: I love
that. he's my favorite Boy Scout song
that you use. I'd like to use it
for our summer camp slide show.
can you tell me the artist and where I can
find a copy to purchase and download?
well, for any of the music that you hear
as a part of the podcast,
go to scoutmastercgcom,
go to the link,
go to the post that contains
any one of the podcast and you'll see
down below, you'll see this little
thing that Amazon calls a widget,
and
within the widget are different snippets
of the songs and they indicate
where you can
select them on Amazoncom
and when you do that
you know full disclosure. here
I get a like a tiny, tiny
percentage of anything
that you buy on Amazoncom
and it kind of helps, keeps the lights
on here at scoutmastercgcom.
you know it's not going to
pay a house payment
by any means,
but it all helps
out. so if you're interested in any
music you hear here, it's going to be
on the Amazon widget. go and take a look.
and if you have trouble with that,
you know, drop me an email, I'll get it
sorted out for you. Howie Jones
wrote in with this question. he said:
while training new assistant scoutmasters
we discuss preferences for how boys
address adults in scouting.
I like it when the boys felt comfortable
calling me by my first name.
they usually call the other dads
and other assistant scoutmasters by their last name.
what are your thoughts on this?
well, it's an interesting question,
Howie. you know my scouts
have mostly always called me
Clark. sometimes they call me
Mr Clark. a lot less frequently,
Mr Green, and I got to tell you
after all this time. I don't think about it
that much and I guess it.
it just all depends on the individual.
I'm quite happy being called Clark
and you know it works
for me and I recognize it
sometimes when they say: Mr Green,
I'm looking around and see if my father
is in the room. but as long
as it can be done respectively and everybody
is comfortable with it, of course,
they don't call you late for dinner.
how about that? Jim Clements wrote in.
he says I was tuned in your podcast by a fellow
scouter here in Orange County.
I can't get through your podcast
fast enough. and
now
now I hear that from some people, Jim, does that
mean they're not over soon enough?
hmm, now
I take it as a compliment.
thank you very much. I'm a new scoutmaster
to an old troop and
there's a tradition in some troops
that boards review
are held from tender foot
through first class
and they're all done on the same night,
one right after the other, with a scoutmaster conference
in between. I don't know
that I like this practice and I don't
feel a scout gets to live and learn
his role within each rank.
what are your thoughts on this? first of all,
thanks for the compliment and thanks for being in touch.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast, Jim.
I think the back to back boards of review
and scoutmaster conferences- they sound a little
bit overheated to me. but I guess
in a lot of cases there's no real reason
not to have them.
I've had it happen to me before where
a scout has completed everything for
one or two ranks and
he's ready to go, and
you know I don't want to hold him back,
and so the scoutmaster
conferences and the
boards of review may come pretty close together,
maybe even on the same night,
and I honestly don't have a problem
with the way that that works.
I do understand what you mean by
it being maybe a troop tradition.
it could be delaying some guys
getting to those lower ranks
and you know it could be
kind of artificially hurrying them along
learning and living
the role within each rank. I'm not sure
I think I'm going to disagree with you there-
that it's either necessary
or desirable to,
you know, spend a great deal of time
on the rank and really appreciate where you are.
I don't see any reason
to slow boys down who've completed
the requirements for ranks,
as laudable as anyone's motives
may be in doing that.
at one time I may have agreed to you.
I would have liked to see a scout
thoroughly embody the things he learned
and appreciate their importance
and, you know, kind of take his time
in a very adult manner,
you know. but boys don't do that.
they're ready to move on.
they're designed so that they can move
at the speed that they want to move.
you and I are looking through the world
through adult eyes and it appears
much different than it does to a boy.
we see them rushing through things
in which they just slowed down a little bit.
I mean, I think that's a pretty general thing that adults do
when they watch their children
and other people's children-
scouts who are full of energy and ambition.
I think we need to encourage them
and not set up any road block.
so you know, like a lot of things in life,
there's two extremes.
there's focus on getting requirements done
as quickly as possible
and then there's also the propensity
kind of slow the process
by imposing additional road blocks on scouts.
what we're really looking for
and the real aim of the advancement program
is building decent citizens and human beings.
our job as scoutmasters
is to maintain this balance
without slowing down. ambitious scouts
are forcing the less ambitious ones forward.
it's a pretty tall order.
one perspective is that-
you know these are not my requirements
and badges to administer or protect.
thankfully, we have a very clear set
of policies and procedures surrounding
advancement. that describes how it works.
all we need to do is follow them faithfully,
and we augment this
with a clear headed focus on the aim.
you know it's always the aim that counts,
and we'll assure that our
scouts have a great experience.
thanks for writing in folks. I hope that helps.
you can get in touch with us
here at the scoutmaster podcast
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening to this edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
just look for scoutmastercg.
when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating,
and you can also call in
if you have a voicemail comment or question
at this number,
484-734-0002.
of course, you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and scoutmastercg on Twitter.
you'll also find us over at google plus.
look for Clark Green,
find out. you can email me
with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercgnet,
at scoutmastercgnet.
now, the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me.
I got a microphone
and I'm trying to help scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
well before we leave you today,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping
until next time.